welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
and he show that was terrible so we're
gonna start doing stuff like that I took
such a squirrely dump this morning cool
I feel like we didn't really get to talk
about it we don't need to here we go how
does this work what are you doing um so
what we're doing is we're practicing
Tantra and one of the key things that
most people don't realize is that orgasm
is different from the traditional
release that comes from climax okay
there we go plug in whatever thing
needed to be plugged
[Music]
i'm christina pazsitzky
well that was fun
so I don't know if you remember the yeah
so we showed you these discussing people
a while ago yeah the cum huggers and
apparently now they're doing
international interviews about it yeah
it's so dumb it's so horrible
she's real gummy and I don't really like
to shit on people's mouths too too much
you don't know I'm like kind of really
open-minded and stuff about it seems
like it's there's so much more to go
after that you didn't need to do that
but go ahead no it's just a little gummy
okay but I I I hate them so much I'm
trying to like what do you hate about
them I just feel like it's it's total
nonsense like it's it's just it's
horseshit
it's so and it's such like a waste of
energy like I feel like they're good
people they're nice you could tell
they're nice people are totally nice but
like feed orphans in Romania or like dig
wells in in Uganda you don't I'm saying
like does it does it really have to be
about coming haven't we haven't we done
enough for orgasms and in society I
don't know I mean if they could really
teach everyone to come hug that's pretty
big there's so many more problems in the
world I mean instead of having the
traditional trajectory where you kind of
get excited and then climax and go to
sleep you're able to experience me I
keep going and you can start having no
you mean that the awesome part were you
nut and you're like I'm out and then
stop talking goodnight yeah get out of
here don't touch my sin is the best part
I know did you notice that he's shorter
than her when they're standing and then
they've made him taller than her in
sitting he look like he put on some rage
saying well when you're calm hugging
maybe your just lay down right doesn't
he look bigger than no I don't think so
look at his face there okay next you
might come down to here but you're in an
orgasmic state that can last for a long
time so then it'll start kind of going
down again so you can eat and you know
play and then they gladly bring it back
up again this guy he's so excited the
dude listening coming 200 so normally my
wife has to tug on my balls
about that pairing studio nuts yeah I
love it she's like 20 years old and he's
a thousand normal ones that camera ready
no he's gross your point of view because
there is that ultimate empty shell you
have no more calm commenting balls do
you know you know what's really annoying
about least two is that they're always
like they're always having a smile and
being character like yeah we're just
always six-day orgasm good great yeah
that's the thing two different things so
you can actually have a full body
blissful orgasm that's actually very
helpful than anything you've done before
without the traditional release and the
drain of energy I think this guy's
confusing
content feelings with orgasming you mean
like if you hug someone and you're happy
about it like endorphins or you just
feel good and he's like we're orgasming
right now no you're not yeah maybe I
don't think he's having an or I think
he's confuse things that were confused I
think he's confused yeah I think he's
quite yeah clearly these people are
misguided
yeah what do you mean like he's tingling
yeah it feels good I gave someone a hug
yeah but roll they're not hugs town
they're rolling sensation how is he
teaching you to he how does how do you
teach to come hug that's a very good
point you can't teach a calm hug either
you can or you can't count hi yeah I
think it's it's a little suspect when
there's two people in the come hugging
you know business and everyone else is
like I hug I come how come I can't make
them line up like you guys need to take
our class that's true if I if I met
other couples that they've taught to
come hug successfully then maybe it's
always them you know I wish we could
send your parents to go learn to come
hug with these two oh my god that would
be the best that would be the best
segment ever ever on anything
your dad would love it yeah I just keep
hugging I'm gonna come after that sounds
like did you come buddy hey buddy I give
you a hug I want to come on here dad I
got trained I come with a hug now pal
Tantra says to hold the sexual energy up
our bodies so the longer we make love
the more energized we get okay yeah I
hate that they're from Los Angeles these
two I did this is the these are the
people that give us a bad rep yeah I
mean she could be going to sleep at
10:00 and by dawn to keep going and then
I just keep getting more energized every
time and about that Rob post though
right any time out when they're not
actually fucking babe they're know
they're talking about fucking to another
time you're an actual Fox yes well I
don't like her voice she talks like the
dumb girl that you do the impression of
yeah um he'll be like we should keep
dunna my
and then I felt energized off the word
yeah like don't you you do know what you
sound like when you talk rightly she's
an awareness though she sounds totally
ridiculous yeah
burst out laughing laughing oh yeah we
all of our emotions and lovemaking so we
laugh at ourselves we cry where's that
dry post question though I think that's
the question that everybody's thinking
about is that her vagina will dry out
from so much I mean imagine if we had 18
hours session no I can't
you said like at night and then by
fucking sunrise it's like you still
don't got no kids no you know say
anything I know even if you I mean let's
say you didn't know do you want to fuck
for it today
[Music]
well here's the thing is that trash and
Bob Bobby we get our freak on and then
it's straight to the the routine we got
flipping out to catch up on we've got
the Shahs of Sunset
this shows the what we've finished Ozark
Ozark you know what I mean like real
married couples you got you got a fuck
and then do the stuff married couples do
yeah
you can't just fuck fuck fuck all the
time no there's other parts to American
College you know I'm saying no I'm
saying you guys got to go downstairs get
your snack give the dogs treats yeah you
know what I mean there's all these
things yeah I do I feel you in order to
do this kind of thing you have to be
connected with your emotions and your
feelings and your channel so that you
can feel the energy moving through your
body and that's what makes it kind of
spiritual practice as well as just
experience as well I feel like studio
London might think the studio Los
Angeles is retarded I think they're
right yeah I'd agree with studio London
on this one yeah this is embarrassing
sorry Angelenos I'm apologizing all Baba
you talk like hey I'm here in
la girls talk like that it's so
embarrassing what time are they doing
this show Allah Allah Allah is all like
you don't necessarily have to be
together to make this work because this
is an energy exchange what are you
thinking you can be in separate rooms to
do this yeah first of all we can feel
each other even when we're apart all by
ourselves just breathing and like
feeling orgasm with God
okay I'm sure your mom would like that
part right yeah that would be the best
part my mom for sure like religious
people there's my mom's face right here
City of London guy's face did you just
say you're gonna come with God yeah
unfortunately that's the end of the clip
that we have I would love to hear the
follow-up to that
okay calm with God I'm sorry what yeah
okay super disrespectful you ever come
with God yeah buddy your mom and I fuck
me with God yeah anyway it's so gross
she would your dad would talk to you
about his cum hugs all the time if he
could do it maybe I don't know he was
never that guy I know some guys you know
their dads would get a little too
familiar a little personal with that
stuff thank God he wasn't I said he was
a mean he's like the obviously with
bathroom stuff yeah but no it's sex
stuff thank God and it's real
traumatizing as everyone here that what
makes who does I've prodded him for like
full bush like big cancer man but he
doesn't actually like know details I
don't discuss it I've never detailed
it's it's borderline incestuous when
your parents tell you about their sex
lives or what turns them on it's like I
don't you're never supposed to know that
stuff one time we were we were on like a
little weekend trip that nasty and there
was a couple they had they were new they
were each other's second marriage and
they each had their own kids and the dad
I was talking to his son was 15 and he
had on some high school sweatshirt with
football on it so he's
I'm talking about football and he was
like yeah I was like his big kid and he
was like yeah you know he plays whatever
position and blah blah blah and then I'm
sitting there talking to him I remember
this guy now yeah and he goes uh it's
like you know I told him man just get
all the pussy you can you know what
things like I told him you know this
this guy get all the puss you can right
now I'm like dude do you really think
your fuckin son wants you to talk to him
about all the pussy he can get no no kid
wants to hear that from his dad no you
know now let his uncle say that if it's
if someone has to but like I have to
fucking it's weird it's weird it's wrong
I don't even like hearing sex jokes like
from like parents shouldn't be telling
sex joke somebody else it's nasty as
well no it's wrong it's totally could
you imagine saying something to LJ they
gettin laid kid like no is so wrong I
want to shut that whole thing down for
like I'll talk like that crazy to
somebody else but not my own kid
what's wrong yeah I I looked at guy he
was like right and I remember I was like
ya know yeah get as much as you can and
you can tell the kid was like mmm he
knew music he's a cute boy is a good boy
he knew he knew like didn't do this yeah
just be normal you just want them to be
normal yeah just don't be gross some
people and I was also a new guy right I
met them at this thing and here his dad
is talking about streaming or pussy in
front of my strange wait a way to do it
dad there's a fingernail question
somebody wrote in what if you're dating
someone for like six months and you're
like hey I need to tell you I used to
have 12-inch fingernails obviously a
deal-breaker when is the right time to
tell someone you used to be a fucking
maniac I think that you wait on that
you wait you sit on that knowledge but
the fact that they used to be and now
they're reformed yeah it's fine right
but you still wouldn't want to give that
away early yeah wait until you go away
to the I love yous have been exchanged
yeah and there's like you if you have
like a weird thing that you're even that
you're into
I don't I'm not an advocate of sharing
that upfront just kind of no I'm saying
like don't you know the introduced like
piss in my mouth I love it you know like
that's not a date one thing to introduce
not a date one but soonish because why
well because that way you weed out the
the ones that are gonna do it you get it
you knock it out early yeah not too
early because it's not your sole
identity so since it's not your identity
you can I mean if you're like all I do
is drink piss and that's what I live
yeah then you need to put if you're like
that's kind of my thing you don't need
to bring that up on this kind of wanted
you want the girl to like you like you
kind of want to rope her in and
manipulate her a little bit more
Moshlings humus sacred like yeah tell
that I'd like to come home be like well
you remember the other day when you're
going the bathroom and yeah she's like
yeah I really wish you to go high huh
she's like flat and you're like well I
already mugged us except to fucking Fiji
so I guess you're gonna have to piss in
my mouth okay
you're kind of manipulating the
situation a little to me it sounds like
yeah that's what I'm suggesting
roping her in and then like you want
this free trip right then you have a
mouth um exactly if you want to get away
with something that weird
you got to manipulate a little bit
that's what I would that's what a doctor
would tell you to do it's interesting or
just be super rich like that also good
millionaire status like that guy yeah we
grog went hammocks or whatever right
shit through the hammock in my now
apparently that's all you need is a few
mil and women are like okay I mean other
that being disgusting that that's fine
because he was like I'll give you a
hundred bucks to shit my hair and they
were like all right
even-steven yeah even see there's no
problem with that no I like it I like
the I like an honest exchange yeah you
know like I we talked about this on the
live show a little bit with Hugh
Hefner's death I don't I don't think he
was some great fucking pioneer I think
he was kind of a creeper and he had a
mansion full of broken broken girls who
you know he lived there for
but he didn't pay them he had like a
weekly stipend and then it was a you
come watch a movie yeah like pajamas and
then he but fucked a lot of them but sex
them because he anyone prank that's true
read read Holly Holly Madison's book
about the butt fucking
yes discuss fucking such a Power Move
like I know some people certainly is
certainly some I know women that are you
know very much into it for the physical
sense a like that that's for them is
euphoria right and there's obviously
people who that's their sexual turn-on
but in and of itself like if you strip
let's say someone's preferences to that
away that's an aggressive move yeah it's
a it's a dominant movie fuck you in your
ass yeah
your butthole is very sensitive and and
oh my god you guys are so disgusting
yeah that's poop I guess they had
credited that pervert he's like oh the
big sexual revolution yeah but it is
still according to like a white guy's
preference not fucking though and only
blondes it was like it was one type of
woman that he liked it was like you know
the cookie cutter big tits Pam Anderson
if you had little hungry tits forget it
you had a big ass forget it was like his
way and I I liked Larry Flynt way better
yeah we talked about this it's my
peddling Larry Flynt yeah just because
it's honest
he was like put that fucking candle
holder in your place right yeah you want
a hundred dollars yeah read it it's
great if you put your hand further up
there yeah and there's no horseshit
mystique of the mansion and living with
Hefner and he was a real it was just
like like I'm a pig and it's an even
exchange here's some cash spread your
beef and there was no convoluted thing
of like how many girlfriends does a guy
have I'm on a bus to my goal wheelchair
okay yeah well and he said to like that
well Holly said in her book that they he
would be like alright you to make out
and then they'd make out he'd you know
jerk it that's cool and then they throw
like the new girl at him so that they
were off the hook for the night all
right deal with him yeah like about that
you got have to
she's like it was cool it kept fucking
my butt though
yeah he's 92 today's exciting and I your
great-great grandpa yeah and I can die
and last night with the live show and
people were like yeah it's great
exposure okay well you think about it
yeah let's think about the stars that
really came out of Playboy
you had your Pamela Anderson that's the
anomaly I think she she was apparently
understand as a genuine like an icon
she's Canadian
but but became an American yeah sure
sure
maybe Jenny McCarthy she was famous
before she did it she was you know I
remember other than that I mean who's
who's really stammering Electra playmate
yeah yep but she was also fuckin prince
and ya know chicken egg
we were you a ho before you know i don't
know i don't know i don't know i know i
don't i just i just you know it's funny
to holly was saying that the mansion was
all rundown and shit too
she's like it's not nice there's old
Astoria but you know they put in bunk
beds in the playmates room I don't know
what why you would give up on keeping it
like a super night because it's
expensive
I'm sure yeah but you've got the money
yeah retile the grotto they're like hey
do you want new carpets and everybody's
like how am i though it's three thousand
dollars that's a lot of money
yeah leave the old carpet there okay I
don't think I don't think there's
Playboy's selling anymore somebody in
the bottle okay we'll get the new girl
down here immediately
but don't you imagine that once the
internet started that who the heck is
even looking at playboy of course when
you can change everything
yeah like no one's buying that shit for
the last 20 years yeah because you used
to get I mean when I was a kid obviously
there's no internet and the magazine was
just tits that's the one thing that's
kind of nice right cuz you were excited
by that you're excited by seeing some
bush right
oh and just like a beautiful body yeah
man that's I'm gonna jerk off to this
right right and then the internet ruin
desensitized you completely
yeah really a naked body so yeah what
can it do can I can we stab it can we
put it in a toilet bowl
why didn't she crying more yeah is she
gagging choking I put my fist down hard
on with that isn't that funny
yeah that's so funny it's really crazy
man yeah I guess my only beef too is
like I always want to see women
exploiting other women and not I know
making the money yeah make the money if
you're gonna exploit the women at least
give them the fucking the money
dickhead yeah yeah make that money come
on sluts make your own stuff yeah you
know because it all boils down to the
finances dude he's got the power they
don't have the power sucks I think these
days I'm not I mean I don't know the
specifics the names specifically the
things but there's definitely some women
I think doing some producing definitely
and look and I'm I listen there's two
sides to this debate in the woman
woman's world there are girls who find
being naked very empowering and very you
know awesome and then there are other
women that just are like it's not for me
so if you know I it's just not for me
personally but I understand why some
women think it's a great thing to do it
feels good didn't really feel powerful
then you know a more power to you but
sure I think that goes if a creeper yeah
yeah old as hell he's super old how old
was he when he died it was like over 90
damn
I would think it's even grosser just to
sleep next to him he's you're all just
old smelling and your body's just you
know just falling apart literally
decaying yeah yeah like you know the
muscle has gone in your face and you
know like he probably like like y'all
right sounds like I breathe oh my god
I'm asleep yeah but that's why his up
fuck you in the morning I gotta take my
shot and I'll fuck you in the butt in
the morning okay that's why the house
was so damn old
you know how old people's houses look
and and they they start to smell and
yeah you're like that's broken and
they're like oh so am i I'm saying like
somebody else should have been like I'm
gonna run this keep this house Christine
I know I think his daughter took over
the dealings of the the magazine and the
don't waste money on his house yeah old
piece of shit he's gonna die and then
we're gonna kick out all these sluts and
then I'm gonna take over so do you think
we think that house I think the house is
like the property's worth a lot the
house is probably I think yeah the house
is probably dogshit but then it's like
what's the house worth in terms of its
significance in other words you know the
historical value of it being the Playboy
Mansion all the AIDS that's been
transferred all the herpes and gonorrhea
that have been transmitted the grotto
can you think of anything grosser at
least I mean Larry Flynt I feel like was
just straightforward and and you know
didn't yes and the girls and you know
the girls can't say no that no one's
saying no why couldn't it just be an
even exchange I feel people said no over
the years now is definitely the day you
found that strip right yeah you should
out of here which is terrible like
that's a harem then you're you're
keeping women hostage you're not it's
not me it's not a fair exchange no you
know this ongoing hostage situation yeah
yeah yeah if you don't do it then you're
homeless oh that's fucking terrible and
real people think he's a big hero this
fuckin asshole yeah I mean I get look
he's great entrepreneur he built an
empire everyone respects that in this
country but yeah by the way how do you
feel about this
our shower farts the safest huh someone
said if you fart in the shower you never
have the fear that Brown is running down
you know feels like a little extra
you're closing up to the toilet you can
just stop it down the trouble of
browning yourself is now removed this is
a stupid question I know I don't
understand why we're doing it's in my
emails I don't know just brought it up
no a shower fart is not this I know what
the thinking is that if I fart in the
shower then the brown comes down I can
just put it through the drain yeah
that's silly the the safest fart the
only safe farts are on the toilet
everybody knows this yeah
that's true it's the safest place you
can fart it's true why would you just
don't go just do it on the toilet don't
go in the shower yet yeah but if you
have one in the shower they're saying do
you let it out of course that's that's
the but that's the droids aviv that's
the whole reason you live you take the
gamble on a fart like that you are
talking about gambling here's a
colonoscopy for it i try to play it at
the live show but it's really a studio
piece i think this is a lady postponed
on a PC really gave me a proper oh my
god oh my gosh that's like old school
yeah oh you know just like that porno
girl yeah that's like that's classic
yeah when you omg omg and she looks like
the moose soup lady which is neat - you
think she does yeah that's not very nice
that was like the moose soup lady after
she had a colonoscopy for four so but
I'm trying to figure out is this
somebody who did the oh I'm oh my gosh
for the show or is that just a
coincidence lady yeah
oh that this is question our show I
think I may be the lady recording I'm
saying oh maybe and she goes hey oh my
gosh no no the lady that recorded said
it oh you know I mean yeah I guess it's
you know it's fun thing to do yeah she's
got that smokers laugh yeah she does she
definitely cheese mousse soup on the
regular
ah Siamese twins good I was wondering if
Siamese conjoined twin murders someone
with the other twin vehemently process
processing and trying to stop the murder
how is the guilty twin sent to jail
assuming they can't be separated that's
an interesting questions so to be clear
they're saying conjoined twins one of
them is like I'm gonna kill this person
he's like you can't fucking do that
right what do you do at that point as
far as punishment well then that they
both have to go to prison well how is
that fair to the one who's like I
objected it's not fair
life's not fair they were born conjoined
twins their whole existence isn't fair I
don't know I think they would have a
really strong case to keep the the
guilty one free yeah I know
here's solution ankle bracelet on the
guilty one so that the good one can lead
their life and then but no here's what
thus the court will say you should have
called the police why he's gonna go
further than that he's gonna be like I
tried and then he fucking threw the
phone down and I was I was pulling his
arm away and he was insisting on you
know well you're in a murder champion
you tell me what happened I'm talking
about the ramifications not the actual
murder itself I know but you've seen
enough sentencing shows and murder shows
you word the courts Lina I don't know I
think that I've never heard a case like
this this is what would be so exciting
about it is that it would be a whole new
field a whole new arena within crimes
and you know punishment very terrible I
imagine they put the bad one in prison
and then the good one just gets to like
watch TV and eat real food in the cell
maybe like it make they divide this
Ellen happen no no for a while that
person those people that are conjoined
are either free or they're locked up
yeah I know you would be really I mean
it's completely unfair to the other
person in either scenario it's fucked up
man I know the whole thing is fucked up
yeah very fucked up like we hate to be a
conjoined twin that's got to be the
worst by the way we're talking about
just woody how do you feel about this um
did you read any of the Harvey Weinstein
stuff yeah I mean I I did it's so great
it's so funny because
no we should introduce that is Harvey
Weinstein founded Miramax the film
production the Playboy for the film
industry and Miramax eventually sold to
Disney and then he started he founded
the Weinstein Company with his brother
and they're you know they're big-time
Hollywood producers what they are they
make movies they're movie producers they
you know his early stuff was like he did
all of Quentin Tarantino stuff so he did
pulp fiction
he's done the whole Tarantino catalogue
he did clerks he's done a bunch of Matt
Damon movies I mean they're he's
big-time so you look up Harvey Weinstein
and the weinstein company you see that
every to every movie right it used to be
Miramax which was his let's see let me
just to give you I mean I want to give
you like a full full you know idea of
those fart Mike's installed you know is
that just a pipe dream they have to like
double side his IMDB you know it's not
even like one list of things it is it's
just every every movie this guy did it's
so many movies man let's I'm trying to
look for like the the huge Wow
Mandela thing here oh the butler I think
that won an Oscar let's see Django
Unchained silver linings playbook that
was that one that's a good one Big Ang
you know man I love that show I miss you
and rest in peace Big Ang scream all
good things the fighter the King speech
I think that won an Oscar or at least
write actor one all right well you get
the point
it's dozens and literally dozens and
hundreds of movies is what he's produced
hundreds of movies anyways so it just
came out that he has been sexually
harassing I guess it's like a big open
Hollywood secret
he's been sexually harassing harassing
women for years for everyone from
interns to actresses to co-workers all
these people he's had eight settlements
yeah
then he released the weirdest statement
where he was like I didn't behave the
way I should have I'm working on that
and now I'm gonna go after the NRA like
a total no he took time off is this
before the NRA he takes time off right
no now he's just distracting people with
that all right yeah that's a total
bullshit nonsensical thing to do it's
saying don't be mad at like you're mad
at me for doing this thing but guess
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do something
that you can get behind right I'm gonna
go after the NRA I fucking absolute
nonsense and if you fall you know he
wants you to fall for that like well
he's gonna go out he's gonna go after
these gun lobbyists it's to just to get
you to not think about smoke and mirrors
guys yeah after that was released more
women came forward and then a couple
where it wasn't like like where he
cornered someone and jerked off out in a
plant in a restaurant and then and then
a couple others and then the board of
directors at that company fired him
because it finally went public yeah they
know of course I mean everybody knew no
one gave a shit until it was made public
and therefore to be held accountable
but anyway I mean if you're gonna get
into the movie producing business
there's no way you get into it people
well especially if you're a mature
active guy he's kind of nebbishy looking
right at old nebbishy unattractive
that's why you become a big movie
producer so you can be like look do you
want a part in this movie you gotta suck
my stuff in my face right right I know
you have a part in a movie right yeah
but but now here's the thing
I honestly think that's an even exchange
which is which one which is hey if you
suck my stuff you get to be a star in my
movie and then the girl go yeah that's
totally fine that's how you feel of
course because this is this is fucking
business is the most corrupt and stupid
thing in the in the world yeah
and that that's just how are you saying
don't sleep with each other every day of
course the right thing no no no but I
feel like it's at least a more honest
way of dealing with shit like in our
business everything else is such a
bullshit yeah
like sometimes I kind of wish some would
have been like look do you fucking you
want this deal like yeah what I have to
do for it you just
I got a jerk off in this plan you got a
watch okay that's it and then we're
straight though everything's like on one
level yeah yeah it's a way more honest
way of doing things didn't take as long
to if somebody were to offer that yeah
yeah you have to struggle all these
years that's what I'm saying get a
special you know that's why I was like
it took me so long to get that I was
like who's ticked away I just show me
the dick I know who who would Netflix
did I you know who think you can go yeah
right here I would have done it ages ago
instead this clean system of you know
normal deals and this and that
I don't you check with me oh right yeah
didn't yeah maybe you but you wouldn't
say no would you know I would been like
yeah do it
look there's this guy he said he's gonna
make it special for me yeah great he was
like I he's got a jerk-off
like calling me or so fine yeah but who
is it like a big producer looks like a
big producer yeah yeah of course yeah
but then then you're out then the deal
is like again it's the Larry Flynt
School of Business where it's like it's
a it's an it's a contract look I went to
law school for two weeks
here's what I learned a contract is an
exchange of something for something else
right very cut and dry you give me this
that's right right you give the guy a
handjob
you get a part in the movie it's so
fucking clean I can't that happen more
I'm sure it does I mean I'd like a part
of movie what who do I have to I know
right I wish she was attracted to me
he's not he's in the he's in the pretty
girls how about like 41 year old moms
yeah sure yeah for sure and I love her
you know the look Hollywood has never
been known for being a non corrupt
horseshit business you know like
actresses
I can't believe it he invited me to his
hotel room well why did you go to his
hotel room oh well like you know what I
mean you'd think that was where the
business deal happens come on up
yeah Ashley Judd came out and she said
that it was a weird you know she goes I
I went to the hotel to meet him and like
come up to the go up to the suite he was
like she's like okay and he was in his
robe it's like she had to bullshit to
get out of there she's and she's a legit
oh talent like she she doesn't need to
suck his dick no of course not no but
yeah I mean he's uh he's out he's out
now and there's so many other dudes
doing that stuff oh yeah a lot of guys
doing that a lot of guys forcing their
dick and balls on you that's the thing
the world is always gonna be full of
creepers I mean I hope to some extent we
can wait them out by shaming them like
we are now creepers in a position of
power is scary though that's all they're
always gonna be yeah dudes that are
powerful are going to some of them are
gonna abused that I know it's too bad
creepers so a lot of people out there
know refer to me and understand that I'm
the Hat comic but then yesterday someone
decided to be a swagger jacker and no
but I you can see that looks so much
better I mean you were clowning me and
you're just like oh I can't believe
you're wearing crazy hats and then also
now the swagger jacker in charge
took my bear Brian at call this style
sucker yeah and Josh gave this to you
last night right at the pod but the
problem is your head is too big let's
show them what it looks like I'm like it
looks so good on me first look at me
look how good I look and look it it
looks like a baby hat yeah look like a
toddler hat yeah no it looks terrible
yeah so this is his grandfather's hat
yeah grandfather's Bear Bryant and yeah
but I mean like it fits my persona and
then you're like what about me
thank you the Hat person now thing is I
thought you were ragging on the hat
person you're like oh I'll do it I'll be
the hat it's not that it's that that hat
looks terrible on you okay this house
that looks good on you though
I'm the taco hat guy I don't know who
gave this to me it was either given to
me by the taco people in Houston that
came and gave us a bunch of tacos or I
feel like maybe Richard Franco the
competitive eater gave it to me maybe
I'm confused James Franco the Eric James
Franco the actor yeah he gave it to me I
just feel like baseball caps look good
on you
yeah but advanced hats like the one I'm
wearing yeah don't look good on you okay
this is like a varsity level hat and
that's for you yeah I don't wear hats
but this one I will because look how
nice it looks but look how good I look
in this it's roll tide you're gonna say
that I don't I don't subscribe to that
say it
I don't said I don't say that you're
wearing this is not an Alabama football
team hat it's a hundred percent in
Alabama football team hat you may show
you yeah okay it's a called a fedora hat
you know this is anything
this is worn by Justin Timberlake he
likes these hats this is a roll tide
okay I don't it's so you mean that the
only people that wear these are rural
tide people yes that's the same guy oh
that's his hat oh my god the famous head
coach former head coach of the Alabama
Crimson Tide see there you go Alabama on
it see so he made this popular this
style 100% well I want he's got good
taste and so do i okay so now will you
say it roll the dice no not no rolling
tides there you go
Jesus unbelievable how old's that guy
well he's very dead yeah so he started
it and I'm carrying the traditional
you're carrying it on yeah you're the
person like I'm the one qualified I'd
definitely look great in this hat you
definitely do
actually you fits you well yeah yeah cuz
I'm cool Justin Timberlake - you're not
cool I'm so much cooler than you what
are you looking at who's texting you
who's sexting there's a big group tax
going on right now about the bet
and apparently Arry and his podcast said
he like I guess he had said something
about not doing some poses so that uh
you know Joe called him out said are you
not doing all the poses Oh Airy was very
defensive Burt's real excited that his
uh sitting heart rate his resting heart
rate is 47 mm-hmm
but anyways I but he also takes like
blood pressure medication which lowers
your heart rate so he doesn't even know
Jesus so he's taking stuff to to alter
it yeah yeah and he's like well
delusional you're manipulating it you
didn't think about that
what's your resting heart rate do you
know it's actually lower
yeah you're but you've always had like
no pulse my resting heart rate is so low
that the my physician sent me to a
cardiologist the cardiologist sent me to
Cedars imaging Institute and they're
like that's you know I even used to talk
about it in my act and they were like so
did you use to run marathons or
something
sure my resting heart rate is usually
between 36 and 44 so that's like you
either have like something wrong or you
have like a really strong heart right
like that's like elite at their hearts
don't have to work as much I've heard
your heart I put my head on your chest
and it goes like this it goes doo doo
doo doo
it's a you're practically dead well I
went his way for 10 years I had every
test run I mean like I think $30,000
worth of tests done this is a few years
ago and at the end with like after all
the multiple days of going injecting me
with things having me run on treadmills
all that stuff they're like yeah it's
got a strong heart I was like that's the
conclusion yeah okay
now is it I hope so I hope it is the
you just have a superior I mean I did
the test today you've gone to where they
do like the ultrasound and you can see
it leaders imaging Institute like it was
a full like multi-day everything that
was ten years ago babe no I went more
recently you did yeah I also had the
cardiac calcium test done where they
score basically it's like a basically
okay like a plaque test yes I've had
that done to zero to a hundred yeah zero
that's great
good yeah I don't want to lose you yet
I'm not going anywhere what I do yeah
there you go
Thanks yeah this is always adorable the
kids say the darndest things you know
dew points in the 20s and near 30
degrees across central Mississippi well
hey there someone's kid but check this
out this is fantastic point out the
weather right now there are parts
everywhere I like that kid
yeah is that our son I wished I would I
wish I'd been watching the news when
that happen to that would make my day
100% I mean yeah watch that kid which
the ratings go through the roof and they
hire that kid to do this the news
everywhere toots and it's gonna rain
today what could be better news than
that I'd love that yeah I wish that
Leigh would do that their farts of dudes
everywhere fantastic and that I love it
what's the deal with weatherman anyways
I mean what do we even need them anymore
you know guys what's the wire the tooth
spoiler toots
why
you remember a while back we did the the
Juggalo episode yes yes what do you
remember about it well the fans are very
unique they tend to attract they turned
a lot of people it's a it's a very
accepting community it's a catch-all
community and there's a little bit of
mental illness in that community I'd say
you think so some drug use but I think
overall it's a positive theme like the
whole thing is like being accepting yeah
they were pretty accepting yeah it was
like a nice theme there was a lot of
like tattoos
right face painting yeah a lot of face
painting is part of the culture I think
a lager diet seemed to be part of the
culture to a lot of carb loading yeah I
mean that's just yeah I didn't see any
verification other than faces but it
felt like that was kind of a theme you
know sugar sugar seemed like it was a
theme to me I don't know if I'm wrong on
that I really felt very much like that
so anyways we you know the the Juggalos
follow the ICP bro insane clown posse
right there was a few people that wrote
in and told us that they were they used
to be Juggalos or they used to follow
ICP and told us a little bit about you
know what you're talking about that it
was accepting it was something to do was
a place to go they're very successful
they've got a lot of ICP yeah I think
there was some discussion of like buying
an island or something and having a
central location for like all the
Juggalos to meet and you know like like
Margaritaville kind of thing like what
Jimmy Buffett right so all the fans can
be together because they have when they
have their big get-togethers it is a
huge turnout yeah yeah oh yeah huge
Turner
[Laughter]
guys great this is from that movie about
that okay nice person I cook like a
motherfucker make some fucking
straight-up fuckin grub okay chicken
fried steak fucking collard greens
fucking mashed potatoes all that fucking
good that sausage gravy biscuits fucking
and everything man I cook like a
motherfucker I want to find a skinny ass
little bitch and make her fat and people
lose weight together it will bond that I
missed that one that was really funny
that was really fun there's that
documentary but this was sent to us and
it said that this is a Juggalo uh-huh
and he's he gives you well he introduces
that that he wrote a song and then he
wants to freestyle his song just for the
public you know okay so this is a guy
this is an original work same one thing
know that I think mistake number one is
if you're gonna sing a song you may want
to go in a nice soundproofed environment
or like a somewhat sounds like indoors
right now you know that you can hear the
traffic driving by right like not in
front of the freeway off-ramp right in a
parking lot somewhere right just sit in
your car even with the windows up very
true very true
so there's sound problems number one
that is a fair assessment but now you
got to give these give them a chance to
do the song of course yes okay here we
go here's the song I can't say she's
worth in machines worth in that got a
gun and got again yeah I got a gun
Terminator
yeah machines but then machines worth in
t 16 T 16 T 16 100% 216 machines width
in machines width in it's not actually I
don't think it's bad I cut him off break
my rep trying to make my rough chung dr.
cymet whoa chomp talk to someone full
machines width in machines worth it
change with machines were thin was that
a bush like a leaves that he pushed
pressed aside I heard like because it
felt like right then he like rush up
against something right there's a
wrestling of some sort yeah like a full
machines width in machines worth 15
where he stepped on something
now she promised on she's worth it
walking down the streets walking down
the streets so far he is he says a line
repeats that line yeah let's call a song
come and then finds another line repeat
that line and then goes back to that
okay yeah but that's what that's what a
song is is that what a song is yeah they
just repeat the same crap over a number
in a I actually think you'd put that he
liked him Tom Petty
yeah same the same category all he needs
is a better producer we gotta hook him
up with like what's that guy's name
Jimmy John with dr. Dre and that Jimmy
Iovine yes right put that guy he would
say if he he would he would because
Jimmy Iovine as Eminem known it is the
elevator you think he'd be like the
problem is he was great at pairing
people up this guy would go oh you need
to really live like that right like
usually you and I should get together
problem is this guy's too heavy for the
elevator
yeah a little bit haters here's the
thing the machine machine was in yeah
the machine within its kind of captain
it's I like it cuz it's deep it could be
kind of a catchy and punk industrial Jam
I don't know it's needs help with the
producing machines with Tim yeah she's
worth ten yeah yeah machines were thin
and he got a gun got a gun Terminator
gun
Terminator again you know coming at you
I mean you and I both here we go I got
it
him and Nick Hawk oh now that's an
elevating rap kind of guys right yeah
both have lyrical talent yep I see him
like you should be with like Rage
Against the Machine oh wow I can see now
you're thinking like Jimmy yeah like I'd
pair him with like that kind of thing
yeah but we know how hard it is to
compose music you remember animal song
that's right and then what was yours
called um I did the butthole song right
it's hard you did Kentucky yeah Kentucky
song yeah those are yeah those are those
weren't easy to make no music is very
difficult it takes a long time to make
music and I did the that Chuy Bravo song
remember yeah how's it good so yeah
those are like these were really hard
actually
[Music]
that's all I needed was this guy's
lyrics well you need a producer oh
you're you're the producer I just did I
just made magic oh you just elevated it
by putting me together with this guy
yeah
damn dude I was awesome homie that's
powerful that's pretty cool that's what
I did
let's see what I have that was really
tight this was my first song we see if I
might if I go better with him
[Music]
butthole butthole butthole butthole why
do my ice cubes smell like a butthole it
was like really powerful but we don't
eat anything that smells like butt holes
Wow see this is how magic happens right
here she's just got to get the right
people in the right room together right
time and that's how classics get made
that's what's happening right now
this is Charles at its sole okay listen
up this is Chad oh the original mummy
I'm in charge here I want you to listen
to me all you niggas need to go to your
mom's house calm and it's good but some
of them you got chat you need a new
poster the ring solution checks out you
know what I'm saying
go to the side slick on the stored
support o me and Tina I got kids to fit
keep it a hundred peace God Wow she
wrote that copying aggressive yeah she
would just that's a great thing about
her you just like read this all right
right big words big words
machines big words
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here I go again here's my song trying
to come back that you're trying to sing
in my song here we go
I kinda like it machines with it she
saying my song
yeah I wish she could tell us the BT
hears he does that's what I'm saying
there's some vision here but he needs a
strong producer like you yep
damn you're like the Jimmy Iovine of the
Juggalo world yeah I feel like I could
probably help this guy I wish we can
have a talent show yep and getting these
people to say that's another good thing
[Applause]
[Music]
seems what then machines with their
machines worth then shoot with then hop
it Halloween Halloween it's my favorite
holiday hey you know he I really wish
you would have played that earlier
because I feel like that was the that
was a hot like that was a client of
build-up yeah I like that yeah strong
finish anyway she's one of the things
I've been working on this is my special
shot I have things to work on now so a
passion product projects you know I mean
yeah so this guy could be your opener
when you DJ we have a couple dad boners
I love dad boners do you want a
justified or unjustified one I like
unjustified unjustified well I guess is
kind of and I guess technically this is
justified because of why but it's still
pretty entertaining machines were then
machines were then he said that
justifies it right smoking pot yeah
taking his drugs but his reaction is
pretty
shadows the shadows forming some kind of
thing there's shadows like fucking trees
growing out of them
holy fuck shadows yeah
drugs are good yep you get that excited
about shadows I mean you should be that
excited about him I guess I mean you
just smoke pot right like that's all
that was yeah I feel like if I had
stayed in Hickory North Carolina end up
like this guy without a doubt but what
is salvia again I remember a red band
was smoking it a minute it was a million
years no I think that's not what was
that stuff like it's like some weird
hallucinogenic isn't yeah yeah induce
visions and oh my god yeah no thank you
plant no thanks yeah I'm too over all
that shit I just need a glass of wine
and I'm like I'm seeing shadows yeah no
it's you know glass of Pinot Grigios all
mom needs but again I mean I know it's
borderline unjustified it's justified
because he's on drugs he's high but I
mean you shouldn't be that excited about
shadows no you know no he's talking no
drugs will do that to you drugs get you
excited here's a here's one I think it's
a little different guitar dad boner
is this Gibson us a guitar kiyose no in
the auction and it's hard a lot of it
and that's apparently the reason that it
was a mystery lot was because it had a
little parlor on the coordinate also
this guy bid auction yeah mystery but on
a mystery item right and now he's like a
bad job that's because like if this is
if this has what I think it has inside
of it
I'm a jackoff right now okay corner
pairs of pliers cuz I'm quite a flimsy
lock and I've managed to em so twisted
mr. faucitt eventually it took us a
while put tip so now he's got the lock
off of the guitar case and he's like
does this or does this not have this
amazing to chance inside of it let's
just hope that it's a real wow that's
the biggest bobbin I have ever ever had
I love seeing someone that exam yeah
this one's making me happy yeah like the
dude it's the guy like doing salvia at
40 in his backyard is kind of a bummer
seeing shadows this guy is like
genuinely stoked about something that
matters
[Music]
dude fifo woke us up at 5 in the morning
with the area fuckin guys that's cool
unreal what did he everything that the
baby drops you know yeah everything
spinach I just like it's not even good
for them 9 news day and they love to eat
everything
scrambled eggs chicken everything then
everything just applesauce look it up
its bits he's so fat from eating toddler
droppings it's really bad I know
FIFO man he hasn't had diarrhea in a
minute so should we try giving top dog a
call yeah yeah what what are we gonna
ask him about anything and part of me
caught up in a while you know sure I
love talking him yeah I miss him I know
I'm he's supposed to come out gonna
answer he's my favorite bad at answering
hey Dad buddy
hey what are you doing I'm driving back
from oh yeah how was it oh it's great
you know yeah absolutely the same
conversation every time I go out there
yeah nothing ever changes you say the
same thing and then same job he's still
a total animal right we go to that what
that he's still a total animal oh yeah
he spilled the soup on top of monkey
today yeah
have your uh then how was how does
driving like cuz that's a good Drive how
does that affect your going to the
bathroom does that make you go more or
less or how does it affect you well you
know I made sure I left the hotel this
morning drive up to see him that I drop
the load yeah I dropped another look
okay yeah and then when we went a lot
too had a mini load so I've had bombs
away three times today and what what
kind of consistency though well the
third one really was just kind of a mini
blaster the first one was was okay I hit
the road it like 7:30 in the morning
then I'm totally screwed after today oh
really yeah so
are you drinking McDonald's coffee on
your way you know home is that what you
do you stop there get a coffee
oh yeah go the drive to get a coffee
yeah three creams - three cleans two
splendas and it's the best coffee right
that's why you're shitting so much me
yeah it's such good coffee but you
shouldn't drink off me as you're driving
yeah I know it's probably gonna make you
shit more and I wanted out you were at
sea on a cruise when that horrific
hurricane came through how was that what
was that experience like being at sea
during that well because we we were on
the south side of Cuba and the storm was
kind of coming through the north side
you know on the northeast side there
that is like the ultimate barrier reason
you have whole island in between so we
didn't get a single weight you know yeah
my big concern was I parked my car on
the ground floor yeah in Miami of the
Miami yes of course I'm watching TV and
I'm thinking that my car's gonna get
flooded I even called the insurance
company from the ship just you know me
just to check the protocol and how do
you well you're not going to believe and
then I hear we can't get in Miami
because there's a sunken sailboat well
wait what did they tell you was the
protocol if the water comes up on the
rocker panels yeah how how was the
cruise food-wise and and and you know
dumping wise for you routine they're on
me and you know basically you know you
can't eat a little bit more on cruise
ship so basically two or three a day I
probably in the extent of the cruise I'm
$25 on the cruise
you counted the whole week Wow
hey would you would you be willing I
found a seminar where they can teach you
to orgasm from hugging someone would you
go to it if I sent you to it with mom
you know I think I mean there was a time
when I was in high school that I could
orgasm without I'll get anybody okay
yeah but would you like to learn would
you like to learn this tantric technique
with mom that would be fun that would be
really exciting right I will I'll get
all the details and send you guys and if
you guys want to go it'll be all
expenses paid okay so if you want to go
okay okay
so we'll do some research and you know
you'll let us know if you want to go
supposed to yeah it's supposed to really
you know enhance things so just I'm just
thinking about it but look I have to run
I love you I'll call you in a little
while okay I think he was more excited
about the all-expenses-paid yeah I'm
good and then like I'll pay for he's
like wow we meet now is it in Florida I
have no I mean I have no idea where I
wonder where I will look it up and if
they teach a thing I always thought I
would send them yeah we said to have a
crew follow them around he's so funny
yeah yeah I would love to see my folks
reporting on that because like my dad be
like it's kind of goofy and my mom would
just be like hey so disgusted so crazy
so disgusting yeah disgusting Tracy yeah
yeah I mean she was a little reticent to
even buy a new bra with me right you
know let alone learn to come on
you know nothing we played during our
live show but I'm just so obsessed with
it
is that guy's weird speech pattern yeah
he does he does video yeah I can't get
him out of my head this is the guy
Texas has really been on my mind a lot
lately and I want to go under the state
in my own way with a countdown I
respectfully dedicate this list to
everyone who has been affected by
hurricane Harvey
all the inflections are wrong maybe it's
a computer Harvey I feel like it's a
computer program talking no like a
highly advanced when it sounds like a
person another video taken one night
showing a door pop open for no reason at
all this wasn't a regular door either it
was a lock security and nobody was near
I guess this could be a publicity stunt
to draw visitors to the Institute but I
doubt they would disrespect Native
American culture by faking all of this
do you think he talks like this to two
people and conversation because he's not
reading come baby
maybe the performing together for nearly
three years so it's hard to tell if they
really pulled out by a ghost or if
someone was just pushing you say the
other side of the shelf and playing a
prank we'll never know for sure but it's
it's like up speak down speak you know I
mean let's all combined I can't place
where he's from either no it's so
bizarre
Texas is hard things were very bad there
I've never heard this guy name his name
is chills
yeah chills
what's up chills mm-hmm let's see if he
has if he has a bunch of stuff on there
not times I ever weird computer robot
yeah
it's so weird I don't think that's it
and so many people he does remind me of
the guy from married and dating the
polyamory that fighter that you just
played yeah Megan
yeah the vocal fry' he has a similar I'm
still a bit shaken up what happened
there's him I have no clue what I saw
and I just want some answers explaining
my family has managed to keep its hands
on a good chunk of land out in the
middle of a chico National Forest for
rad it's a beautiful place down there
there's no cell service no paved roads
and the closest person to us is miles
away that's a person yes six hundred and
eleven thousand subscribers on his
YouTube channel it must be the cadence
you're wrapping people in yeah cuz I'm
intrigued and like I'd like to see his
face I wonder why he's not showing his
identity to the face reveal I wanted to
talk to you about the new channel I'm
launching called game maybe posting
photos of myself through my personal
account on Instagram please add me on
both platforms if you want to stay
connected my DMS are open if you have
any questions or suggestions
so less suggestions suggestions
how's it going guys marvelous Magee here
and I am pleased to announce that I am
actually the winner of the raffle top 15
I guess he keeps his uh he keeps his
face concealed for I don't know keep it
intriguing what people know is we should
do that where are you from why do you
talk like that please let us know chills
make a video where you go the reason
that I talk like this is that my family
when we saw ghosts as a kid it goes
would talk to us in a higher language
and you can process in your brain and it
affected the way that my English
speaking skills developed that's exactly
how he talks Jean you know that right
there pretty wild all right gene
anything else no no all right love you
please go to your mom's house podcast
calm mom Cass please go to Tom Segura
DICOM for tickets please go to our store
mercy I'd watch my Netflix special to a
mother inferior and if you go to
Christina P online store ya merch store
she has new new product shit
yeah it's helping that's that's related
to the special that's right so I've got
some shirts that that I designed we
designed these people yeah and this
merch method yeah calm slash Christina P
it's it's on Christina P online there's
a job there so cool check it out guys I
got some shirts I got a special there
you go
very exciting thank you guys bye gene
he's in pain baby it's not funny
his legs are broken you can't stand he's
collapsing
[Music]
the brass will be done left side we've
done the follow with the time that will
be time left side
[Music]